We'll now go through each of the structured paragraphs in the Gang of Four
description of the composite pattern. First off is intent, which is a summary of
the value provided by the pattern. The intent of the composite pattern is to
describe a way of representing whole-parts hierarchies in such a way that,
that the client treats individual parts and composites uniformly.
The next section of the description is called the motivation section, and
this typically takes the form of a scenario, or story demonstrating that having
a problem, having such a solution would be valuable. Earlier, we used Graphic as
an example. Clients of Graphic shouldn't have to test elements to see whether
they are leads or composites, if all they want to do is copy them, for example.